[Music]
the way back so the way back is directed
by gavin o'connor stars Ben Affleck and
the premise or at least the execution is
a bit deeper than the trailer made it
look a trailer made it look like one of
those movies you know the movie there's
a sports team they're not that great but
they could be they got potential then
the new coach comes in the new coach
sharpens them up and now maybe they'll
win granted in the trailer you totally
get the feeling the coach helps them
they help the coach movie like that I
just there's something about that
premise I love it and I'll always love
it I can watch a movie with that premise
a hundred times and I will enjoy it 101
times but that's just it's not all the
movie is this movie that looks like it's
based on a true story but it's totally
not based on a true story that surprised
me the thing that tipped me off was when
I was watching the movie I was like
everyone has modern phones in this movie
takes place this year so looked into it
when I got home and yeah it doesn't seem
like it's based on a true story
doesn't mean the movies not real though
a movie based on true story it doesn't
make it true but on the other hand if a
movie's not based on a true story
doesn't make it not real these are very
real stories it's very relatable for a
lot of people I think one of those
people being Ben Affleck which I'll talk
about in a little bit a Ben Affleck's
character in this movie he's on a
downward spiral he's obviously running
from something he's trying to hide from
his problems in a bar every night at the
bottom of every glass at the bottom of
any bodily confined it's very dark but
it's also is very real for a lot of
people even taking alcohol out of it I
mean the movie obviously specifically
deals with alcoholism but people tend if
they want to escape reality and not deal
with it they will fill themselves with
any number of vices not trivializing
alcoholism but I'm saying running is it
tends to be a human thing so where's the
main character's condition that's very
focused the theme itself is much more
broad and to expand on what I said
before the thing that surprised me about
the movie is it's not about the coach
that just helps the team which at first
it was surprised I was like but after
the movie ends you're digesting it you
know you're marinating on it actually I
really liked how they did it you're
hoping he wins against his struggles and
his demons it doesn't leave you with
that feeling of oh there's a cure Oh his
basketball team they started winning all
right so he's better now this is one
peek into one chapter of what is an
ongoing fight for people in that
situation I appreciated how real that
was how real that guy I also liked how
the movie left me with that feeling of
thinking about the flow and ebb
people interacting into other people's
lives and sometimes they're there for a
while sometimes they just dip in and out
but regardless you affect people you
interact with and I probably appreciated
that in this movie because I was left
thinking about how much more we interact
with each other how many more doors we
have into countless other people's lives
through the high-speed bandwidth of the
Internet it may be digital interaction
but it doesn't mean we don't leave a
footprint it doesn't mean we don't
impact people so let's try to make it a
better one that was really thinking
about this in Ben Affleck Ben Affleck
you can tell this is a personal story
for him Ben Affleck has history with
alcoholism he's had to go to rehab so
you see and feel his connection with
this movie with this journey you're
seeing on screen
I appreciate that Ben Affleck gives us
that window into an element of his life
logistics may be different but still
it's a peek it does not go unnoticed in
this movie and I just again I gotta say
I appreciate that but in the end for the
way back I really enjoyed it you feel
Ben Affleck's connection with this movie
you feel like after all the Batman
speculation Affleck he's just like dude
I want to get back to work it's a
heartfelt story it's a heavy story and
in the end I feel like my usual rating I
would give it would be remarkably out of
place for this one so I'm just gonna say
it's a good time enjoy I don't know it's
just I feel like the no alcohol required
things it would feel strange right so
the way back have you seen it why did
you think about it whatever you thought
comment below let me know and as always
if you like what you've seen here and
you want to see more click right here to
see more
[Music]
you